willem par nc son équipage vont prendre
la mer pour trouver le mythique passage
du nord vers les armes
je suis écrivain mais c'est moi embarqué
avec vous et je compterai vos exploits
je serai bientôt digne de votre fille
à mon retour je serai riche alors en ou
célèbres mon garçon nous appareils ont
tous
l'horizon
nous abordons des terres encore
inexplorés
c'est il n'existe sur aucune carte elle
est trop à l'ouest
retourné par le nord serait trop lent le
capitaine veut couper à travers la glace
quels sont les risques
personne ne le sait
capitaine
le navire est irréparable larguer les
chaloupes
combien de temps allons maintenir
nous sommes tous perdus rester groupés
non